i want to talk a little bit about former
vice president mike pence it's not clear
to me whether mike pence has
presidential ambitions uh mike pence
yesterday however gave a speech at the
university of virginia and it's actually
notable and painful how terrible and
uninspiring a speaker mike pence is
we're going to look at a couple of clips
now as as many of you of course no doubt
know if you've been following american
politics for certainly the last five
years if not the last 10 or 15.
this
sort of archetypal
prototypical
uh idea of the alpha male is a really
big deal in right-wing politics in
republican politics in the united states
and mike pence in the context of
appearing to or trying to make joe biden
look weak in relation to vladimir putin
made the case that
he went put toe to toe with putin
and he told putin things that he didn't
want to hear
and it's all just so obviously bogus
take a look at this
i've also met vladimir putin yeah
i stood toe-to-toe with him and i've
told him things he didn't want to hear
oh
let me tell all of you
putin only understands strength
and america must meet this moment with
american strength
now there's a couple different things
here
first of all
is he saying he wants a war because if
you look at what the biden
administration has done so far in
ukraine
it's almost everything short of boots on
the ground i mean okay the us hasn't
that we know
carried out
drone strikes in russia
but the us has provided drones to
ukraine so
short of boots on the ground it's the us
has done almost everything that can be
done there's not a no-fly zone which in
theory if there was the us could be
involved in enforcing which is basically
world war iii if as i've explained to
you before
but
this is the guy who was vice president
to trump who said i'm gonna keep us out
of wars and he seems to be saying by not
going fully to war
joe biden is not showing strength or
strength as mike pence says so that's
one piece of this
the other part of this is
i looked at the video
of when mike pence met vladimir putin
and we're going to play it here without
audio the it's just background noises
the audio from when they met
and it's not really a domineering mike
pence when you look at this
pence looks extraordinarily tense
and putin seems to be the guy kind of
controlling the conversation if you
watch it it's a full two minutes you see
pence sort of saying okay and nodding
it's putin whose agenda is dominating
it's putin who's setting the ground
rules and the stakes here
it didn't really seem like mike pence
was the big alpha when they actually met
um so
the idea that pence is the prototypical
strong alpha male is just an absolute
and and total joke it really seemed like
it was putin in control there so nothing
more pathetic than pence trying to be
the epitome of what he thinks his
supporters need to see
as the definition of of manly strength
now just a as a as another note here
the degree to which pence is just a
terrible speaker was unavoidably obvious
during the speech at the university of
virginia yesterday check out this segue
mike pence saying that our hearts are
broken because of the terrible attack
that took place in the new york city
subway yesterday which we'll talk about
later on today
he says you know our prayers are just
with those there
and then he goes directly into talking
about getting to drive a car now that
he's no longer vp and it's a terrible
insensitive segue and he flubs the line
like just everything going wrong this
guy is such a terrible speaker
our hearts broke this morning with the
headline of the terrible violence that
took place on the subway of new york and
our prayers
our prayers are with the injured and the
victims and their families
you know one of the advantages of being
vice president is i get to drive my own
car again
one of the disadvantages is i get to pay
for my own gas
wow what what a deeply in spot just an
electric speaker and really the empathy
is just so sincere
guys this guy is horrible this this guy
he
he really just knows how to soothe
people in difficult situ it's one of the
most uninspiring speakers in the modern
republican party you you feel nothing
other than revulsion creepy revulsion
when he speaks
and
i guess what he meant to say is
now that i'm no longer vice president
i can drive my own car but instead he
says one of the great things about being
vice president
it's just all a mess now the political
question is
does he have political ambitions
presidential ambitions and do
republicans have any interest in mike
pence being the republican nominee right
now the answer seems no if you go to
predict it.org which is these are these
are betting markets you can bet on just
about any political question who will
win the 2024 republican presidential
nomination it's still trump in the lead
over ron desantis although ron desantis
is really closing in on trump and we'll
talk about that later but mike pence
down in fourth place five cents out of
every dollar being bet
is going to mike pence will be the
republican nominee in 2024 so we will
watch it pence is an absolutely horrible
person a terrible speaker but i never
after trump in 2016 you're not going to
hear me say
x will never be
the republican nominee it could be
anybody it could be ted nugent for all i
know
one thing is you don't want to overstate
the common sense and intelligence of the
republican electorate and so i'm not
going to
one of our sponsors is atlas vpn an
awesome company offering free vpn
subscriptions to journalists in ukraine
risking their safety to do really
important work but atlas vpn also has a
lot to offer all of my viewers your
internet traffic can be observed by a
number of parties your isp big tech
platforms even the government that's why
i use atlas vpn whenever i connect to
the internet i don't want to be spied on
i don't want companies selling my
personal information you shouldn't
either atlas vpn protects your internet
connection by hiding your ip address
making you invisible online with just
one atlas vpn account i can protect all
of my devices at the same time you just
turn it on once forget about it and stay
protected and their speeds are great
i've never had any lag while streaming
video content with atlas vpn atlas vpn
is giving my audience 82 off this comes
out to just 199 a month plus you get one
month free just click the link below and
use the code pacman